>> MEIER: My name is Reto Meier.
>> NI-LEWIS: I am Ian Ni-Lewis.
>> MEIER: And today on the App Clinic we'll
be examining Shopping Lists.
>> NI-LEWIS: Whoo-hoo.
>> MEIER: You got to love that intro.
>> NI-LEWIS: All right.
Each week on the App Clinic we take a look
at apps within a particular category and we
give them a technical review.
>> MEIER: Our focus we'll on helping developers
build better apps.
So we're interspersing our commentary with
some technical advice including some code
snippets.
>> NI-LEWIS: And we hope that those of you
who are watching as well as the developers
whose apps we're reviewing will hope, you
know, learn a few tips and tricks and the
best practices creating apps that'll delight
your users.
>> MEIER: We're all about the delight here.
So this week...
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
>> MEIER:...like I said we'll looking each
Shopping Apps.
>> NI-LEWIS: To be more specific apps that
help you shop by letting you write list of
things to shop for.
>> MEIER: Right.
So, Shopping List Apps.
>> NI-LEWIS: Basically, yeah.
>> MEIER: Okay.
>> NI-LEWIS: So there's four apps on the patient
list today, they are Out of Milk, Grocery
iQ, Zoum Task and some French thing that we
don't know how to pronounce but we're going
to call it...
>> MEIER: We'll keep it Prixing.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...Prixing.
>> MEIER: ...it could be Prixing, we're going
to go with Prixing.
It's--if there are any French language speakers
watching, please let producer Lewis know,
so he can correct us live on air.
>> NI-LEWIS: Or just...
>> MEIER: Because we do like to be corrected.
>> NI-LEWIS: Or just mock us in the YouTube
comments.
That's happens...
>> MEIER: Well, that's...
>> NI-LEWIS: ...all the time.
>> MEIER: That's pretty much standard practice.
So we don't need to tell...
>> NI-LEWIS: By the way...
>> MEIER: ...anyone that.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...if the--if the dude that thinks
we work for Apple is back, say hey and we,
you know, I was thinking about like how could
we prove that we're working for Google.
No way.
>> MEIER: It's hard.
>> NI-LEWIS: I mean we're in front of a green
screen here...
>> MEIER: It could be anyone.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...it could be anywhere, yeah.
>> MEIER: We could be in Cupertino right now.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: We're not.
But I guess we...
>> NI-LEWIS: With just a little camera punched
into Andy's old office.
>> MEIER: That will be something.
>> NI-LEWIS: Like this is-this is where--this
where the spy cam was, no.
>> MEIER: It's worth a shot.
>> NI-LEWIS: That's not an insinuation by
the way.
>> MEIER: No.
>> NI-LEWIS: And of course, I'm speaking only
of a hypothetical version of some company
that has no relation in the company in reality.
Moving right along.
>> MEIER: Let's move on.
So we're going to take a quick lightning round
view of some of the apps that's we're going
to be looking at today.
So we're going through them really quickly
now and then dig a little bit deeper later.
So the first of those apps Grocery iQ, I think
it'd best be described as your ultimate grocery
companion it's got integration with coupons,
loyalty cards, it let you share sync lists
between your friends and your family.
It has a lot of really convenient ways to
input items into your list including things
like bar code, order complete, favorite, all
of that good stuff.
So this is one of my favorites I'm looking
for to digging a little deeper into this one.
>> NI-LEWIS: Out of Milk, is less of a shopping
app and more of a list management app that
happens to mention shopping as a possible
application.
And its visual design is lush it has an op-animated
background on the opening screen; it has a
little skeuomorphic touches here and there.
And it has a crisp and responsive UI.
Now, it separates list into three different
categories: shopping, pantry, and to-do.
And as far as we could tell the idea behind
the app is to stock your pantry list with
the items that you used and then move them
to your shopping list when you run out.
And that's sounds like a great idea but as
we'll see there are a few hitches in the execution.
>> MEIER: How smooth are these transitions,
it's wonderful.
So, Prixing, like, Grocery iQ is a full service
shopping companion.
It's got coupons, offers from nearby stores
and keeps hold of all of your loyalty cards
and even offers price comparison which is
I think the only--one of these particular
apps which does that.
It's also entirely in French which is either
a huge bonus or a serious drawback depending
on your perspective.
So we'll go in to a little bit more detail
on that later as well.
>> NI-LEWIS: And finally Zoum Tasks, which
I think I'm saying correctly I have no idea.
You know time again--time and again, we've
looked at apps that had promising functionality
but then found that they cut corners on polish
it's like the developers ran out of rent money
and had to ship.
But Zoum Tasks is the opposite of that.
This app does almost nothing functionality-wise
but the polish is actually above average.
In fact it's so good and so simple that Zoum
feels less like an app and more like a resume
from somebody who wants to create apps for
a living.
But if you look at it in that light Zoum has
some cool features.
We're going to take a particular look at one
later on, the data validation animation which
I think is really cool.
But before we do that let's talk about today's
prescriptions.
>> MEIER: All right.
And before we do that, I want to [INDISTINCT]
a big shout out at to the folks you mentioned
that our audio was in reverse so we had the
person on the left coming from the right audio
channel.
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh.
>> MEIER: Nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: Wait I thought, YouTube wasn't
even in stereo for us?
>> MEIER: Currently it is.
>> NI-LEWIS: Rock on.
>> MEIER: So we've been messing with people's
heads hopefully that's being fixed now.
Thank you for letting us know.
>> NI-LEWIS: This is going to be great, this
is--and it's like total stereo separation.
So it's sort of like the 60's sounds like
a Beatles Record.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yes.
>> MEIER: Which is always our...
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: ...goal.
So...
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, I'm over here and Ringo's
over there.
>> MEIER: So let's have--let's have a look
at the prescriptions.
I'm going to put them behind us because this
is going to be up on screen for a little while.
>> NI-LEWIS: Indeed.
>> MEIER: So, we're looking a shopping list
apps and I think really the acid test here
comes down to one simple question.
How is this better for me than a piece of
paper and a pen?
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
Because a piece of paper fits in my pocket,
you got them all over the house; load time
for a piece of paper is zero, there's no latency.
>> MEIER: There really isn't it.
You type it's there, you don't even have to
do anything neatly.
You can just scribble something in your handwriting
do it times two, whatever.
And it automatically makes sense.
>> NI-LEWIS: Spouses never get mad if you're
looking at a piece of paper and instead of
typing your phone.
>> MEIER: Exactly which is, you know, particularly
important when you're in a shopping center
if you do happen to be holding your phone
up for whatever reason, grocery store seem
to be built within faraday cages.
It's a little unexpected but it means that
if got an app which depends on an internet
connection it's really not going to be that
useful for you.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well I could say in this about
any app, you know, whether in a grocery store
or not...
>> MEIER: It's true.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...there are going to be dead
zones.
So no matter how great your carrier is I don't
care.
So you've got to work with outer connection
and you've got to do it seamlessly.
Now also--speaking of wives and spouses I
want to be able to share my list, you know,
I have things that I need my wife to go pickup
when she's...
>> MEIER: True.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...shopping she has things for
me--sometimes we go shopping together.
So I want to be able to--for her to see my
list items, I want to see her list items and
when I pick something else up, I want to make
sure that it gets checked off on both of our
devices so we don't end up with duplication.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
And that--I think that's a really important
point.
And we want to make that as simple as possible.
So if we are sharing lists send authenticating
ourselves so we can back things up on a Cloud
which--even without sharing I want this stuff
to leave on the Cloud so that it just works.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: And I never lost things.
I want that authentication flow to be as simple
as possible.
I don't want have to go through four pages
and three redirects just to be able to login
into this--into this app.
>> NI-LEWIS: Hey, I don't even want to type
in my email address.
>> MEIER: Right.
When we talked about this before, you know,
every click that you have to make to be able
to get to what you want to do is an opportunity
for a user to go [MAKES NOISE] to hell with
this and hit the home screen button and get
out of your app.
If we're going to count clicks like key strokes
as clicks as well then it's not going to get
too far into your email address before they're
like that to hell with this.
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
I personally never run an app if it asks me
to type in my email address.
My email address is on the phone but there's
other things that you can do to save people
time, too.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: I mean the shopping apps are
the kind of thing where most people buy the
same thing.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: Give me some auto complete, I
look at my contacts, remember...
>> MEIER: Favorites--things I have bought
beforehand.
>> NI-LEWIS: Sure.
>> MEIER: You know, let me add those things
again.
Yeah, like you said bar codes kind of--let
me just take a picture.
Maybe you don't even need to write it down
just take a photo of whatever I want, that's
enough to [INDISTINCT] me.
>> NI-LEWIS: Get final location and microphone
permissions.
So that if I'm in my bedroom sobbing and I'm
all alone, it will remind me to buy beer.
>> MEIER: It looks like you need whiskey.
Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
>> MEIER: That would be a useful feature.
Um, I'm not sure if any of the apps we looked
at today offer that but I guess we want to
find out.
>> NI-LEWIS: I might be going a little far
there but, you know, you know.
>> MEIER: Well, it's good to--it's good to
set lofty goals.
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
Okay.
So those are the prescriptions we have.
Let's see how our apps measured up.
>> MEIER: Okay.
So yeah, lets all--let's dig into each of
those.
And so the first app that we wanted to take
a look at is actually, uh, Out of Milk.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: Which I think we could take a look
at.
So this is--this is the...
>> NI-LEWIS: So...
>> MEIER: ...the Google play listing.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, exactly and I just have
one thing to say about this.
Which is I think that the basic design of
the logo is good, it's fun, it gets the point
across but that little to do list on their
feature graphic is probably twice as big as
it needs to be and their logos half as big,
you know, so they should really be rejiggered
some.
But let's not spend too much time on that.
Let's bring up the app on our giant fake phone.
>> MEIER: Oh, why isn't the giant fake phone
coming up?
>> NI-LEWIS: What?
>> MEIER: Very disappointing.
>> NI-LEWIS: What happened?
>> MEIER: I'm not sure, try unplugging it
and re-plugging it back in.
>> NI-LEWIS: That always works.
>> MEIER: The big reveal for the giant phone.
>> NI-LEWIS: Okay.
>> MEIER: It's interesting.
I'm seeing no lights on the on the giant phone
controller so I'm going to duck out of sight
to try and figure out why that is.
>> NI-LEWIS: I mean...
>> MEIER: Have you got the--have you got that...
>> NI-LEWIS: ...did this thing just get too...
>> MEIER: [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: ...hot, do you think?
Because it seems like it always fails on it
sooner or later.
>> MEIER: Oh, here it is.
>> NI-LEWIS: oh.
>> MEIER: Is it coming up?
All nice.
Now try unplugging it...
>> NI-LEWIS: it's a...
>> MEIER: ...and re plugging it back in.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, it's coming.
Oh, giant fake phone.
Well, this is really good time to remind our
audience that we are doing this live and that
is why we have an excuse for this sort of
nonsense.
But since we're doing it live we'd be happy
to take your feedback, uh, I'm pretty sure
Lewis is watching the YouTube comment stream
and I think he's also taking a look at our
G+ page.
So if you want to get in touch with us and
give some questions, comments, anything you'd
like us to talk about that we're not already
talking about, we'll see if we can squeeze
you in.
>> But we have been told that Ian, you're
a little loud.
So we probably have to fix that on the [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: That always happens.
>> MEIER: All right.
So we're going to try to make Ian a little
but quieter.
And I'm also going to try and restart yCast
real quick because...
>> NI-LEWIS: Good Lord really?
>> MEIER: Well, I think that's the only way
we're going to get that video up.
>> NI-LEWIS: Maybe so.
>> Video stream on pause for a moment and
then you will come back.
>> MEIER: That's right.
So we will be...
>> Go and try it live viewers.
>> MEIER: We will be paused.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> MEIER: But do bear with us.
Don't all run away and we will be back in
just one brief moment.
Okay.
>> Steady it goes.
>> MEIER: Yeah, we're still staying online.
Can't we ask those who are staying online?
I think we're back now.
So thank you for patience.
Those people who were still around.
Frustratingly, we still don't seem to have
any actual video.
>> NI-LEWIS: And we had it there for a second.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
It was working great and now--oh.
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh, hey.
>> MEIER: It's there.
>> NI-LEWIS: All right.
>> MEIER: Just when we were about to give
up for old time.
>> NI-LEWIS: In deed.
Okay.
>> MEIER: Thank you for your patience everyone.
We--and the system is broadcasting.
>> They were like, yes.
>> NI-LEWIS: Okay.
All right.
We're going to do this Baby Weatherman style.
>> MEIER: But...
>> NI-LEWIS: Nice.
>> MEIER: It just happened.
>> NI-LEWIS: All right.
If you're still watching, the reason we're
looking confused is Reto tripped over a cable.
>> MEIER: Just the monitor it's okay.
Nothing is wrong.
>> NI-LEWIS: Just the monitor, yeah.
Okay.
So are we're still going?
>> MEIER: Yeah, absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: Cool.
>> MEIER: We're just wasting time.
>> NI-LEWIS: Excellent.
>> MEIER: But in other ways, behaving entirely
as expected.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, Thank God we had an excellent
rehearsal.
>> MEIER: Yes, that's right.
>> NI-LEWIS: But a fold rust rehearsal for
this session.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
Nothing went wrong.
>> NI-LEWIS: That's exactly why everything
is better.
>> MEIER: I really feel the preparation in
a way which has really come together here.
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
I think the human element is better.
It's the technology that let us down.
You know why?
Computers can't rehearse.
>> MEIER: That's right.
Oh, right.
Perfect.
So i'll you...
>> NI-LEWIS: Okay.
>> MEIER: ...into quite now.
>> NI-LEWIS: Wait until you want to drive
Out of Milk so I can be Mr. Weatherman?
>> MEIER: Oh, I would love to.
>> NI-LEWIS: Now, one thing that we did in
rehearsal actually that I--we can't see the--you
see what I did there?
I'm going to call it rehearsal.
So one thing we did earlier that we won't
be able to reproduce is the entry experience
in Out of Milk is a...
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...significant amount of time
that goes through a--I think nine or ten page
tutorial which--it would have been nice to
be able to skip.
Now the other thing that Out of Milk does,
it is--it ask for me to sign it--oh, there
we go.
Yeah.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: So it's this thing.
>> MEIER: So there's no obvious way to get
past this other than scrolling through the
whole thing.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
Exactly.
And then it asks me to sign in.
Now it gives me the ability to sign in with
Google and with Facebook.
A couple of issues there.
First, I would like to sign in with whoever,
honest--honestly.
But I realized that, you know, standards being
what they are or not.
That's not necessarily possible.
So it's great that we have Google and Facebook
as options.
The only problem is if I try to sign in with
Google it takes me a webpage or WebView which
I think we don't have because we're in one
of those Faraday cages.
>> MEIER: Exactly.
And you could buy groceries, yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: It's incredible.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: The problem is...
>> MEIER: Here we are.
>> NI-LEWIS: Now there we go.
The problem is now I've got to fill this out
and unless I completely trust this app I shouldn't.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: Now, this is something a lot
of people don't know but I think tech savvy
people know this is that on a phone going
through this flow isn't going to add to your
security at all because the app developer
can actually read directly out of that WebView.
This is OF flow was created for web apps that
run in standard's compliant browsers not in
a WebView that sits inside another application.
So with the WebView or I--I'm sorry, with
the web app on your desktop, the question
is do you trust your browser.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: With this sort of thing the question
is do you trust the random app creator that
put this together.
Personally, sorry Milk guys, but I don't.
So...
>> MEIER: It's nothing personal, he trusts
no one.
>> NI-LEWIS: So we'll talk a little later
about how to make that easier but let's remember
that this is not the way to go if you want
your users to stay engaged.
>> MEIER: Definitely.
>> NI-LEWIS: Now...
>> MEIER: So let's start--so what we've got
here out on the front page is, again, sort
of this dashboard pattern, how that you can
see, it's--it seems like an odd fit for this
app.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, it's kind of cool because
you get this, you know, little like moving
background behind there.
>> MEIER: Yeah, it's nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: So it's pretty but it's a complete
waste of space and it's a waste of my time.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: If I want to categorize my list
that's great, but I'm not really sure that
these three categories are the way that I
would do it.
Even if it were I think I'd prefer to swipe
between them or have some other way of choosing
them rather than the dashboard, even though
the...
>> MEIER: It's...
>> NI-LEWIS: ...dashboard is pretty.
>> MEIER: And as you can see us we're going
through each of this list.
They look identical, they just have a different
heading, and so I really just want to be able
to click this and choose between those different
lists.
>> NI-LEWIS: They do behave a little differently
but that's...
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS:...not actually a plus.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: So for instance let's check out
the shopping list if you want to add an item.
You type in the name of the item or you speak
it because it's got the microphone icon there,
that's nice.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: What happens if I add an item
from the pantry list though?
>> MEIER: If I go to the pantry I'm automatically
given a list of suggestions to add which is
really nice and I can still tap them in which
is a good step but it does show me all of
these things and it's really nice to have...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: ...that same functionality in both
parts of the app.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
I mean you feel like you know what was just
going through these guys mind if they're thinking,
"Oh, we've got this functionality for the
pantry" and so we'll split that off from the
shopping list that has this different functionality
but it turns out that, that functionality
is useful everywhere.
Now the other thing that I kind of wish this
app did differently is when it comes to checking
of item.
I mean what are the two things that you always
do with list apps?
>> MEIER: Yeah, things when you check them
off the stuff.
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
If--and this is I think probably just a rule
of thumb that we can say for certain, but
no.
Roman Nurik should probably weigh in on this,
but here's what I think.
If the two most common behaviors in your entire
app can't be accomplished without a double
tapping or long pressing, there's something
wrong with your UI design.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, how am I going to check out
an item there?
>> MEIER: So, yeah.
I click the item and I can click done so that
works.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
So if you--if you just single click you're
going to see that toolbar come up and that's
great.
At least it's discoverable but why isn't there
a check boxes next to the item?
>> MEIER: Exactly.
And in fact if I long press which is in particularly
discoverable it does the--it does the done
but what I really expect this to do is when
I long press to get a contextual action bar,
something that should let me multi select
the items and do many of the things here.
So bulk move, bulk delete, bulk copy this
sort of things.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: All part of the contextual action
bar will be really nice to use the button.
>> NI-LEWIS: Now, we talked a lot about apps
where it seems like the developer ran out
of time and to me this is the--this is the
evidence.
I...
>> MEIER: It's almost the to do list of stuff
that we need to figure out how it works in
the--in the UI properly.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
There's a gargantuan list of features that
obviously exist in the bowels of the app but
there's no UI to launch them and there was
very little thought given to how these things
fit together.
So it's just this jumble of different things
that you might want to do, you know, sharing
versus settings versus history, all of these
things could be done in way that makes them
task focused.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: And discoverable but instead
they're sitting on this gargantuan menu bar
that's almost unusual.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
And so that's probably the biggest piece of
advice that I would have for the--for the
people behind Out of Milk is think more about
the typical user work flow.
One of the most common things that they were
going to--going to want to do make it as simple
as possible.
You don't want to have to think about, "Well,
how do I move something from my" like you
can see this.
Every time I want to change something I'm
clicking a three or four different places
because I don't want to have to hit back because
that implies that I'm undoing something.
I just want to change my navigational location.
So I want to click here and then choose watch
list but I don't and I have to go back.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: And then click pantry, it's already
two clicks.
And so how do I get my chicken broth here?
How do I get that into my shopping list?
>> NI-LEWIS: Well...
>> MEIER: So...
>> NI-LEWIS: And there's no app affordance
on this thing that looks a lot like an action
bar but isn't and...
>> MEIER: Exactly.
>> NI-LEWIS:...again, I mean we say this a
lot but, you know, go nuts with your custom
design but if you make a design that looks
like a built in Android feature either make
it work exactly like it or rethink your design
because otherwise you're just going to confuse
people.
>> MEIER: Exactly.
So really I think the suggestions I would
have here is to simplifying navigation, simplify
your workflow, optimize the app for whatever
the most typical or desirable workflow.
So it should be really easy to add things
to your shopping list using all the order
complete magic which is in pantry.
When you bought things it should move into
your pantry because you bought them so now
they're in your pantry and then from there
you should be able to click--do a single click
which then moves it back into your shopping
list.
Then--so then you'll have an app which continues
to grow and become more and more useful the
more you use it without having to do a lot
of pre-population.
No one is going sit down and put everything
that they currently have in their pantry into
this--into this app to make their life potentially
easier in the future.
It needs to build on its self.
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
Well, I think we've probably spent enough
time talking...
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: ... about the particular things
that Out of Milk made have done right or wrong.
Why don't we talk a little bit about some
of the technical things that they might be
able to do to make this app a little better
friendlier?
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
I may have seem to have lost my click app,
I just had it.
Oh, I probably put it down somewhere while
fixing things.
>> NI-LEWIS: It's over here, yeah.
Yes.
>> MEIER: So one of the things which this
app does which a lot of these apps do or at
least one of the key things is functionality
sharing list since so the way that you do
that is you, you know, choose someone you
want to share with, sends him an email, says
hey, you know, this is being shared, you can
follow a link to it.
Now, what would be really neat is if you could
take that one step further and actually have
that link automatically open up your app.
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly, it doesn't even have
to emails, any web link...
>> MEIER: That's right.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...that I want to have do something
in my app, right?
>> MEIER: That's right.
So if you, you know, browsing the website
associated with this or someone, you know,
if your wife tweets you a link because that's
just how she rolls.
>> NI-LEWIS: Sure.
>> MEIER: You want that old to work and so
you can...
>> NI-LEWIS: You got your bitly link or whatever?
>> MEIER: Yeah, precisely right.
>> NI-LEWIS: Sure.
>> MEIER: So what you want to do is you can
actually intercept any URL that's click within
an application by registering an intent filter
against the activity that you want to react
to it.
And so what happens then is whenever that
URL is clicked within a WebView browser, text
tube, anything really--it's going to launch
any view intent and the URL associated with
that click action is going to be included
as a .parameter.
So, you can create an intent filter like this
one and that's--you can see here that specifying
the host, the protocol type, the schema I
should say and the path.
This is really important, so here we're going
to say we're going to intercept links for
my website, but not everything.
I still want people to be able to view my
website on the device, but if they click on
a shared shopping list then that's something
that my app can handle and so you can do something
really clever with this and that's--you can
have your actual website redirect to Google
Play or to a please download my app type link
so if the app is installed, you can view the
shared L's right away but if isn't then you
can encourage people to install the app.
>> NI-LEWIS: So if the app installed then
it will just eat that link because it fit
that particular form of my website.
>> MEIER: Exactly.
>> NI-LEWIS: Or the apps website...
>> NI-LEWIS:...but if the app is not installed
then it's going to cruise right passed and
into the web browser or whatever you have
set up to handled generic links.
>> MEIER: Precisely.
Precisely.
The effect, the users going to be prompted
with the opportunity that either use your
app to launch to fulfill that link or to view
in the browsers so the options is still there
and this is on the YouTube does or something
that the Google Maps does also trying to create
that magical experience.
>> NI-LEWIS: Now I have to--I have to admit
the first thing that came in to my head when
I heard you talking about this is what if
I just intercept my Google Play link?
>> MEIER: Well, that's interesting so why
would you want to do that?
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, maybe I don't want to set
up--maybe I don't want to set up a server.
I don't want to set up a redirect, maybe I
don't have the ability to do that.
>> MEIER: Well, see that would be the challenge
because you are wanting to intercept a link
using an app that isn't installed.
>> NI-LEWIS: Indeed.
>> MEIER: So let me know why.
>> NI-LEWIS: But that's the whole point, the
right if the--if the app is not installed,
let me go to Google Play...
>> MEIER: Uh-huh.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...if it is installed.
>> MEIER: So if someone trusts to follow a
link to your app...
>> NI-LEWIS: Yes.
>> MEIER: ...on the process when your app
is installed, you wanted to open your app
instead of your web.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, I'm not saying me but if
a friend of mine asks.
>> MEIER: Of course, a guy you know.
Yeah, I guess you can do that.
I'm not entirely what the used case would
be for but yeah, you can do that.
>> NI-LEWIS: I--we actually have had that.
That question goes through text support.
>> MEIER: There you go, so yeah...
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: ...I guess that's interesting.
>> NI-LEWIS: So probably better to put a redirect
in because you want to have some control...
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...over what you're doing...
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...and I--and you definitely
don't want to be in the position where users
can't get to your play link to update or to
see reviews or whatever or...
>> MEIER: Exactly.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...you know, God forbid you messed
it up and end up hijacking play for everybody
so...
>> MEIER: Yeah, that's enough to [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: ...I bring it up as a counter
example...
>> MEIER: Okay.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...but there's some really interesting
things you can do with this.
>> MEIER: Totally.
So let's--let's have a look, one of the--I
think there was another technical tip--but
you wanted to provide that if I'm not mistaken.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well actually, you know I was
thinking about how much I hate typing in my
email address and there hasn't really been
a wonderful way here for to fix that.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: But we just recently released
something called Google Play Services and
it turns out that the Google Play Services
API which is an extra in the Android SDK just
like billing or licensing and these other
things you can add on.
Has a way to register and, you know, essentially
federate accounts without having to write
a bunch of code without having to deal with
aloft and importantly without having to requests
extra permissions.
>> MEIER: Nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: So what I--what you want to do
is same thing I did which is check out this
link, it's the Google Developers link, that's
were the Google Play Services live because
a Google API is not an Android API, but it's
a really nice add on and you're more or less
guaranteed to have it on the system if you
have for your above and a recent version of
market.
Now it's not exactly that easy but it's really
close...
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...this is a backwards compatible
library.
You don't have to be update the phone, there's
no OTA involved as long as you read the documentation,
you'll understand how to use it.
So what can you with this?
Well, let's take a look at this code.
First thing you often want to do is get the
users account so that you can figure out who
this user is.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: So Google Play Services has a
nice convenience method to help you do that.
This works back to Froyo.
Now we did add a convenience--a similar convenience
method to the framework in ICS, this backwards
compatible so you just launch this intent
and it will launch the picker dialogue for
accounts and you can say which type of accounts
you want in this case .com.google is the name
of the account and that will bring you back
a string that in fact I think it's on the
next slide we'll use that string in a--on
activity result.
The string will be an identifier for the account
now, you'll probably notice immediately that
the identifier for Google accounts is actually
your Gmail address but you can't count on
that.
That's not at all required and it very well
may change in the future.
So, what you really want is an ID that you
can associate with this user to tell you two
things first, they are who they can say they
are in the sense that it's really them saying
"Sure, use my account" and second you have
some sort of ID that you can use to federate,
you know, you have--you have an ID to where
you can store in your database that's not
going to change and every time you see that
ID come from an Android device, you know "Oh,
yeah that's--this key in my database."
So the way you do that in this example is
use the user profile API now, this is actually...
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...I think it's an open ID left
over actually.
>> MEIER: Okay.
>> NI-LEWIS: But you don't need know anything
about an open ID to use it.
All you do is specify the OWA of scope which
I actually had to do a little digging for...
>> MEIER: All right.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...so I made sure and put it
in this slide, I--it's, you know, OWA of:
blah, blah, blah, blah, and then ended up
with user.profile.
Now, once you've got the scope you send it
to Google Core or--all right, I'm sorry, Google
Play Services and it will try to require you
a token.
There's two things that can happen at this
point you either get a token or you get a
response back that says "Sorry, you can't
have a token, but here's why and here's the
way to fix it."
Because usually the reason you don't have
a token is because the user hasn't actually
authorized you to look at their information,
so if you launch that intent, what you'll
get is a very nice little dialogue that essential
says "This app wants to look at your basic
profile data, do you want to allow them?"
And as long as the user clicks there and says
yes" then you'll get a token back that you
can use to make web service calls to this
API.
Now, if you like me the first time you get
in to a calling web services, it feels a little
tricky...
>> MEIER: Yeah, sure, yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...fortunately with this API,
it couldn't be easier.
Let's take a look at the next piece of code.
All you do is get a URL connection and set
up the particular URL with the token that
you were given, so that's all you need to
do.
It's a one call thing and the response that
you get back will actually contain the users
profile data, it's a JSON format and we can
take a look at that right now.
So this is an example of what you get back
if you query my profile data for instance,
you get my name or at least what I told Google
my name is.
And you've got a date of birth, but no year...
>> MEIER: Uh-huh.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...no email address, no way to
contact me.
>> MEIER: So all the people have their year
of birth sort of tied to their email address
so it could be tricky if you get that access.
>> NI-LEWIS: That's quite possible or it could
just be the year of a very pleasant scotch
that you drink once.
>> MEIER: That's quite possible.
>> NI-LEWIS: Indeed.
The important thing here is you're getting
enough information to be able to identify
this person when they come back so there's
some--you get the first name and last name
so you can actually refer to them by name,
people love that...
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...but more importantly you get
an ID, this is actually their Google+ ID which
is tied to that user and won't change the
way an email address might.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: Or we can do the way a name byte
in fact.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
Absolutely, that's really nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: So don't make your users type
an email addresses and passwords anymore,
this is a click-through interface that does
the exact same thing and unlike the WebView
that we saw earlier it's secure.
>> MEIER: Actually secure, which is a nice
touch.
>> NI-LEWIS: Indeed.
>> MEIER: All right.
So...
>> NI-LEWIS: Let's move on.
>> MEIER: ...let's move on.
Let's have a look at the next app that we
wanted to check out is a Grocery IQ.
>> NI-LEWIS: Look my head is an IQ.
>> MEIER: That's got to be a first time for
everything.
Let's take a look.
It's--so this is--so this is an app that I
quite like, Grocery IQs probably my favorite
of the apps that we looked at today.
And you can tell that the developers behind
this app have really spent a lot of time and
effort trying to create something that is
fully featured as possible.
You've got all those--the obvious sorts of
stuff that you like.
So you can see here it's got all the complete--which
is nice and fast and rich.
And it actually goes a step further.
And you can see here once you've ordered--once
you've added these things in, it automatically
character--categorize system for you as well
which is a really nice tip.
You can see all of the sort of obvious things
are right there.
You've got the checkbox and extra things as
well so you can just add things to your list
really easily, check them off really easily.
And so it's got that cool functionality of
what is this app for?
How does this make my life easier?
It's really obvious right off the bat, which
is nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
So, one thing that I really love about this
app is the way that it knows everything already.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: And unfortunately we can't show
this but it actually does have pictures that
would actually be sitting right along here.
>> MEIER: Nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: That'll...
>> MEIER: Well, it's really handy, ain't it?
>> NI-LEWIS: ...that'll show you a little
bottle of whiskey for instance.
Because...
>> MEIER: Just in case you don't know.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...just in case--well, yeah,
in case you forgot.
>> MEIER: Well, and this can be really useful
because it seems kind of obvious.
I'm so glad that there's a list.
So I know what it looks like.
Except that maybe someone else added it just
to the list and you don't know what it looks
like.
And so having a picture right there from something
someone else added is really useful.
And this is a really good example of an app
which is trying to one up paper.
So what paper is just whatever you write down
here, you get to know what category it's in
which means you know what aisle it's in and
you can then sort by aisle so you can make
sure that your shopping trip is actually optimized
using the trolley itself and the problem.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
It's amazing how the presence of these Cloud
databases just contains the most mundane app
into something really magical.
I don't think there's a worldwide database.
And I certainly couldn't find a lot...
>> MEIER: Exactly.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...of my favorite things in this
particular app.
But, I can see that if I'm in the right location,
it's really, really handy because not only
does it know the sorts of things that might
be available, it also knows what they cost
and can compute the tax for me.
So it can do a lot of mundane tasks without
me even thinking about it.
I love that.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
And I think that's what this app does really,
really well is it has thought about its workflow.
And so the first time I use it, it's instantly
useful.
And it's already adding things to my list
which I wouldn't have thought of.
So, all of the data that pulls down from the
web around the products that I'm adding is
instantly useful.
Pictures, cost, categories, all of those things
are great.
And what I really like is that they've gone
that extra step.
So, by default, it's just going to go to your
grocery store.
But you can actually add your own shops.
And so there's a whole foods in a safe way
near my place that I shop at.
You can then add the aisles that they have
and reorder them.
>> NI-LEWIS: That's right.
I found that by pressing [INDISTINCT] I have
a little...
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...trouble on there.
But what was disappointing is once I started
looking at a list that has, you know just
two options, any store or groceries where
I'm thinking, "Wow.
It would be nice to add another store to this,
then I didn't know how."
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: It seems like they missed a golden
opportunity here to make the app flow even
more magical by...
>> MEIER: That's good.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...looking at this and saying,
"Well, if a user sees an incomplete list,
what are they going to want to do?"
>> MEIER: Add something to it.
>> NI-LEWIS: So why put that anywhere else?
>> MEIER: Exactly.
>> NI-LEWIS: Why put that functionality somewhere
else?
>> MEIER: So it would be nice to see this
working the same way that the account manager
works.
So you can choose between your account so
you can one add one if it's not there.
And it helps you to understand the functionality
that this app provides.
And there's a lot of it and so I'm trying
to put that front and center and easy to sort
of expand your use of the app, is I think
a really--a real benefit.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yup.
>> MEIER: It does a lot of clever things like
when you have checked out, so once you've
finished removing everything from the list,
add that to your history making it easier
for you to then add things back the future
lists, adding favorites is really simple.
But, this is something that you actually pointed
out to me Ian, is the favorites handling could
be a little sensible.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: If that's a word.
>> NI-LEWIS: I love that word.
Let's use it.
>> MEIER: It's a pretty good word.
>> NI-LEWIS: Sensible.
Yeah.
Well, like you pointed out, the favorites
tab here already has a star on it.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: Why don't I just see that star
in the list here?
>> MEIER: Exactly.
And in fact, if you look at that list, then
there may be a golden opportunity here because
we have this current server on the side here,
which are kind of meaningless in an Android
world, at least...
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: ...from today.
>> NI-LEWIS: I think it makes sense if you're
on an OS where--there you're guaranteed to
get a right to left sliding animation when
you move from a list item to a detail.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: But that's not what Android does.
It has a zoom animation.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: And...
>> MEIER: But you can do like a funky kind
of vortex zoom icon on the right that...
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
But we wouldn't do that because we're not
insane.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
Particularly because--and this is the important
thing is that the animation between activities
isn't guaranteed.
It can be changed by OEMs by different platform
versions, and so you don't want to make any
assumptions as to what screen animation is
going to happen when you click something on
the screen.
>> NI-LEWIS: You really don't.
So, what we have just trained users to think
in Android is that if you click on a list
item, it will take you to the details for
that list item.
>> MEIER: Precisely.
>> NI-LEWIS: That is just an expected behavior.
So there's no point in putting a chevron here,
but you could certainly fill that space with
something else; a star.
>> MEIER: Like a start maybe.
>> NI-LEWIS: And there's a checkbox on the
other side.
If you wanted to you could even go nuts.
It's a little bit small but, you know, you
can usually get away with one or two things
on the right-hand side...
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...that has nothing to do with
the details for that list item.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: Because it makes your user's
life easier.
And of course there's always the idea of putting
a little tear off corner to bring up a contextual
item list or to long press for contextual
items.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
So I think, you know, that would be a nice
thinking will be, you know a really simple
replace the carrots with stars and then just
add that favorites flow, you know directly
into the user experience.
The other couple things that I wanted to highlight
real quick is at the top here, we have coupons--we've
got coupons, we've got loyalty card integration.
It's basically everything that you could want
in.
And it's really an app that's really spent
a lot of time thinking about what is it that
you want a replacement shopping list piece
of paper to do to really enrich that experience
and make it something that you can justify
using instead of just writing it down.
>> NI-LEWIS: And like you said, it really
builds on itself.
It's useful the moment it loads.
And as I want more functionality, it's relatively
easy to find.
So, even though the design of this app is
fairly dated and you can tell that the buttons
that come from the Froyo Era and the tab bar
hasn't really been used in a while.
And we can probably do a view pager and some
other nice things, it doesn't matter.
The core design, the flow of the application
has been really well thought out to make it
easy for users to get the most out of it.
Although I did need to point out and this
is just for that one dude that was on our
YouTube page earlier, "This is a menu button
of shame.
Shame.
Shame."
>> MEIER: It's a--but really what it is, is
just a really obvious example of the fact
that this is an app which people spend a lot
of time and effort making it really great
probably hasn't been updated from that design
perspective since the initial designs when
this app came out.
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
>> MEIER: And so that's--the big piece of
feedback we would have for Grocery IQ, love
the app.
Let's maybe take the opportunity now that
the Halo things has been out for awhile, we
have the design sites so you no longer have
to play the guessing game of what the Android
guy is going to do next.
>> NI-LEWIS: Great.
>> MEIER: It's up there.
It's being pretty standard.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: And that's definitely a style in
a design that we're going to be sticking with
for awhile.
So now I think it's a great opportunity to
maybe think about a tablet app, think about
doing a redesign.
And in fact, Roman, Nick and Adam are going
to be performing a design maker about on Grocery
IQ next Tuesday.
So it will be interesting to see what they
come up with.
>> NI-LEWIS: And stay tuned by the way.
We don't have a time yet for this but some
time in the next couple of weeks, we are going
to do an interview with the design team and
they are going to explain the whole menu button
issue.
And we are going to get set straight, so...
>> MEIER: So, yeah.
That should be interesting.
Stay tuned for that.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> MEIER: So, there's a couple of specific
technical implementation of details which
I wanted to cover as well.
So these are things that Grocery IQ does well--well,
could do better.
And again...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: ...I think in both of the cases
here, its stuff which is probably postdates
when this app was built.
So hopefully it's stuff that we can point
out to the developers and they can implement
as well...
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
>> MEIER: ...to make the app that little bit
neater.
So the first is around the way that the app
sends updates.
>> NI-LEWIS: Okay.
>> MEIER: So right now, there's a menu option
that you can select to say how often you wanted
to pull the servers to check to see whether
you...
>> NI-LEWIS: Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Did you say pull off the servers?
>> MEIER: Yeah.
And you've seen the problem right there, right?
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, yeah.
Hey, 1985 called they want their data update
method back.
>> MEIER: So--and the bad news is the highest
number you can set is five minutes which kind
of makes sense because I want my shopping
list to be bang up-to-date, but I really don't
know that I want my phone firing up the cell
network and transfer a data back and forth
between the server if [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
There's got to be a better way.
>> MEIER: There has to be.
And in fact, there is a better way.
And that's Google Cloud Messaging.
And that's what I'm going to attempt to display
on the screen behind me.
So you start off with your app that's running
on each of the user's phones.
So that's what we're looking at here.
Now, what you need to do first is register
the phone with the Google Cloud Messaging
server.
And that's going to uniquely identify this
device will temporarily use or run it with
Google.
That's then going to send a message back up
to the device.
And stop pointing because clearly I'm bad
at this.
Weather presenter, not in my future.
But what you now have on each of the devices
is a unique address which you can then use
from your server via Google Cloud Messaging
to talk to that particular app.
So, the next thing you need to do is actually
send that down to your server.
And now what your server has hopefully is
a hash of the username or user identifier
that has logged in to that particular phone
and that phone combined.
And now you have an address that you can send
messages using.
So, you're basically all set to go.
So what happens now is a user using that tablet
at home makes a change to a shopping list.
You send that down to your server.
Your server goes, "Oh, okay.
Yup.
Updated the lists.
Now, I need everyone to who has access to
this shared list to see what the changes are."
So it is now going to send a message to the
Google Cloud Messaging to each of those apps
using the addresses which you've got registered
with it.
Google Cloud Messaging is then going to send
that to each of the devices which are going
to get pinged using temp receiver and they're
going to go, "Oh, okay.
Look, I have changes to this," so they then
have the option to ping the server and ask
for those specific updates, or if it's small
enough change, you can actually package it
in the payload of the message that you're
going to send.
Look, Ian's in the cloud.
So that's basically how it works.
And so you don't ever have to do polling.
You're basically just updating the server
and the server is directly transmitting that
information to each of the devices which need
to be updated.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yay.
Okay.
So that's a--that's a great tip and something
that you should really check into because
that really didn't cost you anything.
>> MEIER: No.
It's entirely cost-free.
But it does...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: ...save your device--your user's
this device has a lot of battery life and
actually means that the latency between changes
is reduced as well so it's kind of win-win.
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
Now, of course, this isn't magic.
I mean it's not like we're, you know, we don't
have a way to just phone up that device there's
still is polling involved but the important
thing is that all of the messages are set
in one batch instead of each app making its
own network connection and possibly screwing
up the network connection using not only bandwidth
but battery and CPU time as well.
>> MEIER: Exactly.
Okay.
So there's another tip as well which I wanted
to point out and that is about how to share
those contact with.
So at the moment...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: ...you hit--share this list and
it will pop up a dialogue asking for an email
address.
Which is reasonable.
But I don't memorize email addresses anymore.
>> NI-LEWIS: No.
>> MEIER: You know why?
>> NI-LEWIS: I don't memorize anything.
>> MEIER: Yeah, I don't know this email.
I don't because it's all in my Gmail.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: Or my Google+.
And all that sync to my phone.
So everyway I have to contact with someone
is already in my phone.
So I kind of resent having to type something
that already exists.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: So, rather than asking users to
copy and paste email addresses, you can use
the contact picker.
So they can choose the contact from the existing
contact list.
And the way that works is actually pretty
straight forward.
You start by creating an intent again.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: A lot of things tend to work with
intents and this time the action is pick and
the data that you want to pick from is contacts
or to put it more specifically, it's slightly
less clearly be ContactsContract-ContentProvider.
>> NI-LEWIS: I love it.
>> MEIER: All at one time.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, these things are actually
just made to become tongue twisters ideally.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
And we love the alliteration here in Androids
so there'll be a lot of A words as much as
we can anyway.
So you send out that intent, start an activity
for results.
So, that's going then open up contacts picker,
users going to click on something and it's
going to send you back a URI.
And what this massive screen full of code
does is actually pretty straight forward.
We get a URI to a particular contact back
from the contact picker.
We're going to extract idea by using query
on a--on a content provider, once we have
that we're going to use that ID then make
another query this time on the database for
the Content Provider which contains the email
addresses.
So it's basically going to say "We have this
ID, what is this associated email?"
And that's what you see here is that that
last part of actually pulling out the email
address from the query result of that course.
So once you've done that you've got the email
address, it's good font then just pop that
into the edit text make the user can confirm
it, modify it necessary before it go on and
send of the email.
>> NI-LEWIS: Cool.
>> MEIER: So it's a fairly straight forward
process and I think something which really
makes life a lot easier and in fact you can...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: ...possibly even go a step further
here which is--well, you have the email address
and if you are logging people in using their
email address is then maybe you don't need
to send them an email if they already had
an account maybe you can just send a notification
direct to the point.
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
Maybe you could do both.
>> MEIER: Maybe you could do both.
Exactly.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> MEIER: So let's have a look.
So let's move on to the--to the next app which
was Zoum tools.
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
So Zoum Task has a gorgeous feature graphic.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: And really nice design and honestly
it does almost nothing.
It's a--I mean it's a bare bones task.
I mean it doesn't seem...
>> MEIER: It's a beautiful looking app...
>> NI-LEWIS: It...
>> MEIER: ...which has all of the marketing
stuff down perfectly.
It's really an example of exactly what you
should do to make sure that your app is likely
to be downloaded.
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
Yeah, absolutely the--there's a ton of stuff
that we could talk about starting with where
they got that check mark.
I don't think we should even show that.
>> MEIER: Probably not.
>> NI-LEWIS: I'm going to end up in a sweatshop
in South East Asia somewhere.
But what I did want to point out is what happens
when you fill out a form incorrectly and you...
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: Obviously you never want to punish
your user for doing something but there are
certain cases where you have to do data validation.
You know that there's probably something wrong
when you've tried to add a task without name
for instance.
Well, that's the example they chose.
>> MEIER: Exactly.
So why don't I hit okay here.
But I haven't put in a task title and if you'd
see that.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: It's wiggling.
It's wiggling...
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
>> MEIER: ...it's [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: It's [INDISTINCT] I love it its
going "No, no, no."
So it's a universal signal that you got something
wrong in this particular piece of UI.
>> MEIER: Pay attention to this bit.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right, but it doesn't give you
a toast that says, "Please do not press that
button again."
It doesn't give you a dialogue that says,
"You screwed up.
Press okay to accept this and move on with
your life."
Instead it just gives you a little nudge to
say that something...
>> MEIER: Maybe...
>> NI-LEWIS: ...a little off here.
>> MEIER: ...we'll get this.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: This isn't the only way you could
do it.
I mean you could turn the field red; you could
put an exclamation point next to it.
The point is that you want your data validation
to be A, unintrusive and B, specific.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: And people should not have to
read your text in order to figure out what
they did wrong.
This is beautiful because I could use this
even if I didn't speak English.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: I love this feature and I really
like the way that they've implemented this
particular little shake.
It's buttery, it's nice and it just gets the
job done.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
And that's--I think kind of the resounding
theme for this app is that it's designed really
well.
It's simple, it's got those nice little bits
of polish but almost ironically or certainly
different from a usual expectations.
The polish is the functionality isn't.
Now, in fairness we are comparing it in a
category up against apps that are design to
optimize the shopping experience rather than
specifically to do list which is really more
an example of.
But even still if you look at an apps like
Tasks from Tasks team they kind of do a neater
job.
Apart from anything else it doesn't synchronize
to a service any where.
So if it's--the only place that I can get
to it is on my device and if my device gets
flashed, this is gone forever.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yup.
>> MEIER: And that's kind of a--it kind of
sucks.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, yeah.
That's gets old.
Okay.
So, I don't think we're going to talk about
Zoum Task anymore and we are just about out
of time if we were going by real world time
as oppose to the fake time that we use when
we screw stuff up in the middle of the show.
>> MEIER: Around that time it doesn't count.
>> NI-LEWIS: No, it does not.
>> MEIER: And so let's have a look.
So one of the--I think the last app that we
wanted to look at was Prixing or Pri depending
on how you choose to miss pronounce a French
word.
And I think about this app, the defining feature
of this app is that it is entirely in French.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> MEIER: Which is fine.
There's certainly no problem with that except
that we don't speak French.
>> NI-LEWIS: No.
So it's...
>> MEIER: That makes [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: ...difficult for us to...
>> MEIER: ...on for us to fairly sort of evaluate
it.
And so we won't really go in too much detail.
>> NI-LEWIS: I will say that I wanted to use
it.
Because...
>> MEIER: It's a beautiful looking app.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...it's looking really, really
pretty.
They've used pictures every other of it makes
sense.
They just--there isn't any boring text.
It's laid out like a magazine.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: I really, really like it.
>> MEIER: It makes you want to go shopping.
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
To the only concern hat I have is as I tap
on some of these beautiful pictures it's taking
me to WebViews.
It's taking me out of the app, so I do question.
Any app that launches a WebView makes me think
well maybe this app isn't actually all that
functional.
>> MEIER: Yeah, it gets [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: You know what; it takes me out
to the Internet.
>> MEIER: ...to why am I having to go to the
browser at all, WebView to do that functionality.
Again it's hard to be...
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> MEIER: ...entirely fair without knowing
exactly what we're pressing.
It may say click here to view this on a web
page but...
>> NI-LEWIS: That is--that's quite true.
That might be right.
This particular style of picture might be
the universal I'm a web page picture in...
>> MEIER: Exactly.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...certain French speaking areas
of the world.
We have no idea.
>> MEIER: Yeah, so then it looks like a really
fully featured app.
Certainly the reviews that it gets on Google
Play a very, very encouraging.
It's a beautiful looking app.
It's got things like coupons and, you know,
loyalty cards and all this sorts of stuff
that we saw in Grocery IQ.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: And Out Of Milk but unfortunately
we can't really review it because we don't
speak the language.
Now that does actually bring up two kind of
important points.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: And one is that I should kind of
be able to use an app like this without being
able to speak the language which is written
in.
>> NI-LEWIS: Possibly, yeah.
>> MEIER: You know, it maybe stretch but here
I wasn't able to get very far at all before
just going--doing--know what to do.
>> NI-LEWIS: I can't believe you don't even
have like French speaking friends though.
>> MEIER: I probably--well...
>> NI-LEWIS: I mean...
>> MEIER: Yes, it's a shame there's no French
[INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: You're not even American.
>> MEIER: ...in the Android team.
That would be...
>> NI-LEWIS: No.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Anyway.
>> MEIER: But since--so that maybe it's [INDISTINCT].
So--and this goes for people running English
language apps as well.
See what happens when you translate all of
your apps into gibberish and see whether it's
usable.
I think it's...
>> NI-LEWIS: That's a fantastic idea.
>> MEIER: That's kind of a really good way
to see how does the phone work?
What are the...
>> NI-LEWIS: UX fuzz testing basically.
>> MEIER: Exactly.
Yeah it's like well, if you put this in front
of someone and they don't know what the words
are, can they still figure it out?
Does--what are the buttons they're pressing
by default?
Because whatever flow they're doing instinctively
you want to be the right flow.
And so you want the words to just back up
what they intuitively feel that they should
be doing.
And the other two of course is maybe consider
an English translation.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: There's a lot of English speakers.
And it's probably one of the--of if not the
largest market in terms of your Android consumers
are going to be English speakers.
>> NI-LEWIS: English.
>> MEIER: So considering investing in that
translation particularly because Prixing has
been around for awhile.
Really popular.
A great way to grow your user base.
Unless the apps is only used for in France
or French speaking places.
[INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: In which case it makes a lot
of sense to go ahead and just take it out
of the English speaking market.
Because remember anytime that you have your
app presented to people who aren't going to
be able to use it whether it's because their
phone isn't high tech enough or they don't
have the right API level or in this case they
don't have--they don't speak the language
that you do.
You're going to get at least some people who
are frustrated and give you bad reviews because
of that and you don't deserve that.
>> MEIER: No, you want to make sure that you
are--you know we encouraged people to build
apps which is usable by as many different
people and many different devices as possible.
If you choose not to that's fine.
But, you know, don't encourage negative feedback
by offering it to people who aren't going
to be able to use it.
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
Cool.
Well, I think that gets us to the end of our
app list.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
Let's take a look at some of the specific
prescriptions that we have for this app.
So these are the things that we would love
people to do to take the apps to the next
level.
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely, I can't wait.
Before we do though it occurs to me that we
haven't check in with producer Louise in awhile.
Hey producer Louise, how's the YouTube stream
going?
>> YouTube stream is going very well.
There are questions going around Grocery IQ
being available in central Europe.
It appears that it is not.
>> MEIER: Okay.
>> So their concerns about geographical availability.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> People are very excited to see the code
samples.
They are encouraged to use the Cloud in terms
of publishing their apps.
>> MEIER: That's good.
>> So that's very good.
>> MEIER: Good to hear.
>> They're also--some of influence feedback
for talking about how you would get prices
for items from different stores and put them
into the app.
>> MEIER: Excellent.
>> It's probably unusual that people would
do that and shop around but for those who
want to--like to Google and add that to apps
like Grocery IQ.
>> NI-LEWIS: I think that's a great idea although
that's sounds like--no, I'm sorry did we mic
Producer Lewis?
>> MEIER: No, but...
>> That's what--I was speaking loudly toward
Reto.
>> NI-LEWIS: I hope so...
>> MEIER: I can say that just...
>> NI-LEWIS: ...yes.
He...
>> MEIER: That's feedback coming through.
>> NI-LEWIS: Okay.
Well, just in case.
So, the question--the last question was just
around collecting information from different
store, pricing information, things like that.
Absolutely but I think this seems like one
of those things were there's a business opportunity.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
I mean I could go around to a bunch of stores
and collect price information but what would
be even more interesting is if I sent a dozen
guys around with, you know, back pack cameras
or something and they collected price information
for me and then I'll put that in the Cloud
and monetized it in some way.
So, something to think about.
>> MEIER: And I think its interesting challenge,
when you're looking at price comparison especially
for it to be really useful with an app.
You want to be able to pull in a real time
feed of process for all the different competitive
supermarkets--strictly we're talking about
groceries and I'm sure there APIs exist but
probably not in a way that will allow you
to do exactly that because...
>> NI-LEWIS: There's no saver system for groceries.
>> MEIER: It's probably not what the groceries
store want you to do.
>> NI-LEWIS: No.
>> MEIER: Have all the same list and know
exactly which shop to go to.
It's...
>> NI-LEWIS: I'll tell you--let me give you
an real world example though because--you
know, as we've discussed on the story the
whole point of going to college and working
for Google is that I don't have to count pennies
on my grocery bill.
So, I don't.
I don't care how much my beer costs, unless
is it at one place that sells the 99.95 beer
for 17.95...
>> MEIER: That's seems...
>> NI-LEWIS: ...those guys ripped me off man.
But I tell you what do I count, calories...
>> MEIER: That's true.
>> NI-LEWIS: So--yeah, after working for Google
for three years and 30 pounds heavier than
I was when I was when I started.
I love to get my calories down, that's something
that I would love to see budgeted in the shopping
app...
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...and it has just so happens
that at least in the United States, the FDA
the government has a database of many different
foods and their nutritional information.
And you can see apps that do this, there's
a--I think the weighting's apps does it.
There's a several fitness apps that do it...
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...but it would be great if that
could be in the shopping app too.
>> MEIER: Again, because this is really going
back to what we were saying, you know, it's
really about trying to add as much functionalities
as you can which you--we have to go to other
places and the beauty of this is you have
to create a shopping list.
And what were really talking about here is
incentivizing you to do that shopping list
in this app.
By saying if you write it down here once,
then suddenly we will be able to give you
recipe IDs--ideas based on the things that
you bought.
We'll be able to tell you the Calorie intake
of the things which were in this list.
We can keep track if your international pre-buying
a budget over time to see whether it's trending
up or trending down.
These are the sorts of things which I think
can really add benefit.
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
>> MEIER: But tell us--let's get specific...
>> NI-LEWIS: Let go ahead and take...
>> MEIER: ...let's have a look...
>> NI-LEWIS: ...yeah.
>> MEIER: ...we'll step out of the way of
the Out of Milk and again I think we mentioned
this before would be--wouldn't been useful
to copy this text somewhere we could actual
read it, but we'll let you guys read it and
give--I guess overall thoughts.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right, well I can almost read
it because I have a better...
>> MEIER: [INDISTINCT].
>> NI-LEWIS: ...eyes than you...
>> MEIER: Excellent.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...and then so yeah...
>> MEIER: Oh, so I have better glasses but
the good folks in me Google Drive team kick
them off my face in soccer this week so, I
had to revert...
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh, you don't even know what
that cost me, to set that up.
Okay.
So for out of milk, there's several designed
things we would like to be seen but I--the
functionality seems really nice and we just
like it to be easier to get to you so how
about the contacts picker, how about letting
me sign in with my account without having
to put in my email address.
Let's go on then.
>> MEIER: So, the next app was a Grocery IQ
and we really like this app.
>> NI-LEWIS: Why did we put this behind [INDISTINCT]
>> MEIER: No, we can put it in front certainly.
[INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh, there we go.
Okay.
Great.
All right.
So, you know, what I can't actually read it,
I lied.
>> MEIER: [INDISTINCT] the thing about Grocery
IQ, I think really what it comes down to,
apart from this specific things that we've
got there.
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh, look at us.
>> MEIER: [INDISTINCT] oh, I see, so we can
actually read.
It's a nice touch.
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh, that's cool.
>> MEIER: It feels with [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh, wow.
Thanks for this Chrome book Luis.
>> MEIER: So shinny.
>> NI-LEWIS: I can't believe how useful it
is.
Okay.
>> MEIER: Really, I think that the key thing
for me for Grocery IQ is, you know, you got
great designers they created a really great
work flow, user flow, for an earlier time
in the Android Ecosystem.
I'd love, love, love to see this app.
With the same functionality just--and the
same design as frankly but just making it
consistent what we currently expect to see
in Android.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, it just needs to be updated
and it needs to use Google Could Messaging
instead of polling, that's really important.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: And then as we said with the
other apps, a little bit tighter integration
in terms of contacts, URLs, and account management
would be really welcomed.
>> MEIER: Basically one of the things we're
talking about had been relatively recently
added to Android and so I think it literally
is a case for this app for something which
has been designed--has done really, really
well...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: ...has the functionality it needs
and now it just needs to have those occasional
refreshers to take advantage with the new
features with Android...
>> NI-LEWIS: Great.
>> MEIER: ...platform has.
>> NI-LEWIS: Move along.
So, Zoum Task.
>> MEIER: Keep going.
>> NI-LEWIS: Keep going tracking buddy.
>> MEIER: It's a--its beautiful, its wonderful
to see someone who's putting so much thought
and effort into the designs side.
Definitely an inspiration for people in terms
of what you should you be doing on your Google
Play listing in terms on your icon design
and creates something really compelling...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: ...just need to follow through now
and see some more functionality added into
the app.
>> NI-LEWIS: Do you know what's going to happen
now?
>> MEIER: What's going to happen?
>> NI-LEWIS: Roman's going to pick this one
for Android design and action and he's going
to prove us wrong he's just tell us how everything
should be different.
>> MEIER: Happily I've looked into the future
and I happen to know which of the two apps
that Roman would be reviewing so, it won't
be Zoum Task.
And that's it.
>> NI-LEWIS: Because now I think about it
Zoum Task didn't have any gradients anywhere
so Roman wouldn't care...
>> MEIER: That's true.
>> NI-LEWIS: Roman really loves it.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
He probably does.
And the last app we looked at was Prixing.
>> NI-LEWIS: And Prixing the main problem
for us is that we just don't speak this language.
I don't know why we reviewed it, not speaking
the language.
>> MEIER: We love a challenge.
>> NI-LEWIS: And we just wanted to--just sort
of flaunt our ignorance.
>> MEIER: In it--if like we need to flaunt
it its clearly obvious to anyone who cares
to look.
It actually was the highest scored app, both
on the Trailer page and Moderator because
people really wanted us to look at it.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: Which implies there a lot French
speakers watching the show so bonjour.
And that's about it as far as I can go in
French.
>> NI-LEWIS: And that's only because it's
also a network protocol.
So, we will...
>> MEIER: [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: ...maybe get some French speakers
out here to...
>> MEIER: Absolutely, or maybe...
>> NI-LEWIS: ...to help us out.
>> MEIER: ...or maybe get some...
>> NI-LEWIS: The entire graphics team is French
basically.
>> MEIER: Exactly, you shouldn't be too much
of a stretch.
Perfect, so...
>> NI-LEWIS: Okay.
>> MEIER: That was each of the apps you wanted
us to look at and we're basically up to an
hour, so that's all for today's App Clinic.
Roman and Nick and Adam will be performing
a design make over of some of today's apps,
in particular they can look at Grocery IQ,
and Out of Milk which is great, there two
of our favorites.
That will be on Android design in action on
Tuesday.
And we will also be checking in on the patients
which we looked at today and in the previous
weeks over the next few weeks to see how they're
coming along.
>> NI-LEWIS: Great, now make sure visit our
Trello page to nominate the apps and the categories
you like to see us review.
We have decided to move away from Moderator
because Trello is way more hip, we threw Moderator
on the ground, not a part of their system.
Next week we'll be looking at Trello to see
if anyone has nominated Halloween themed apps.
Reto was convinced that such a thing existed...
>> MEIER: It's a big holiday, there's pumpkins
on everyone's porch.
>> NI-LEWIS: I believed that there was no
such thing.
>> MEIER: I may have been proven wrong in
an instance.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, next week it's going to be
trick or treat.
Were going to--were going to review what ever
we feel like.
>> MEIER: Exactly, if you are satisfied with
Ian proving me wrong then by all means, don't
nominate any further apps if you would like
to see me proven right, please, please...
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh, absolutely if you have a
candy scanner, if you have a where's the best
house in the neighborhood for loot, if you
have a...
>> MEIER: Wait...
>> NI-LEWIS: ...something that automatically
locates home made pop corn bowls and UNICEF
pennies, go ahead nominate that stuff, we
want to see it.
>> MEIER: I'm sure it exists.
I refuse to believe that they don't.
I think people were just boo guarding the
good Halloween apps, because they don't want
other people--if everyone has an app that
tells you where the best place to get candies,
then there are no best places to get candy.
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh, the incredible's quote, nice.
Well, will see next week we're going to try
it out, see what happens...
>> MEIER: See what we get.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...in our special Halloween episode,
where I think I'll be going as a doctor.
>> MEIER: Outstanding.
I don't know how you come up with these things.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-uh, I'm cleaver that way.
>> MEIER: Thanks for joining us, my name Reto
Meier.
>> NI-LEWIS: I'm Ian Ni-Lewis.
>> MEIER: And this was the App Clinic.
>> NI-LEWIS: Take care.
>> MEIER: Thanks for watching.